the mandatory use of the arrive can app
has been criticized by frontline border
agents uh themselves those are folks
that uh are part of the the the union
folks that work in the in the government
uh mayors tourism councils chambers of
commerce our u.s border partners
actually it would be easier just to list
those who support it and that's only the
government sir
uh it is adding delays it's quadrupling
the time at
customs we know that that's on record uh
people are being wrongfully put under
house arrest because of a glitch it is
funk it functionally does not keep up
with the political health restrictions
uh it has been cited as having privacy
issues uh and the one-time secret
exemption uncovered last week uh proves
that it's not even about viral spread so
in the face of the overwhelming evidence
uh on its problems and the criticism why
is the government not abandoning the
mandatory use of arrive can and why are
you instead making it permanent
mr chair miss landsman in january
claimed that the vaccine mandate at our
borders would lead to food shortage and
empty shells at our
grocery stores she was wrong
in may she claimed that the
transportation vaccine mandate with as
causing the congestion and if we
stopped it it would solve the congestion
problem once again she was wrong so i
can tell you mr chair canadians would
forgive me why i'm skeptical about her
assessment a rye can is not contributing
to the congestion in fact a rife can is
a useful tool that helps verify the
vaccination status of an individual
before arriving at our borders if we
didn't have a right can the the
processing of arrivals would take longer
time because it would have to be done
manually ten more seconds minister
please arrive can is actually helping
process arrivals much faster and helping
reduce congestion do we have any
evidence minister that the arrivedcan
app is suppressing cross-border travel
and tourism because you know tourism is
very important we have a wonderful
country and our neighbors to the south
are uh wanting to visit our great nation
as far as you know is there any evidence
that um this is being suppressed
15 second response please minister thank
you there is there is no evidence
mrtrakus however i am aware that several
border communities have been flagging
this as a as an issue and we will
continue to work with them on ensuring
how we can increase
the facilitation of of international
arrivals but let me just state this at
airports international arrivals
currently at
99.5
compliance rates that is almost 100
there is no evidence whatsoever that a
riot can is causing any problems
minister if there was no scientific
basis for mandates um as has been
indicated by officials
why would your government institute a
policy that infringed on canadians
rights uh that didn't have scientific
basis and then call a snap election a
couple days later
you mean the non-scientific mandates
that was implemented by municipal
governments you mean the non-scientific
based mandates that was implemented by
provincial governments you mean the
non-scientific based mandates that was
implemented by the private sector
without required from government you
mean the non-scientific based mandates
that was implemented by universities you
mean the non-scientific based mandate
minister i'm talking about the mandates
implemented by the federal government at
airports governments around the world
i'd like to quote one of your officials
in court documents that were reported on
by rupa subramanya um and one of those
officials is uh is on the on the call
today actually and let me quote in an
email to the extent that updated data
exists or that there is clear evidence
of the safety benefit of vaccination on
the users or other stakeholders of the
transportation system it would be
helpful to assist transport canada
supporting its measures that's a quote
from aadm mccrory now the the mandates
were set to be implemented but your
department didn't even have the
information that uh that indicated it
was necessary or based in science to
just circle back to your question about
the science that's being followed by
municipalities and provinces they have
all eliminated their mandates since yet
you have not so if you're following the
same science they are why have they all
lifted their mandates but you have not
uh mr chair first of all let me start
off by saying vaccines have proven to
have saved lives and continue to save
lives at a moment in time where our
public health system is under a lot of
pressure vaccines is in continue to be
an incredible tool in saving lives and
protecting the health and safety of
canadians and our health care system
the federal government has suspended
most of our mandates the only mandate
that we have is at our borders like many
countries around the world and it is
done to again to ensure that we minimize
the importation of the virus and that
protect the health and safety of
canadians and let me point my honorable
colleague on top of the all studies that
have been done over the last two years
just the last two months two different
studies one was done by the canadian
medical association one was done by ubc
the university of british columbia that
demonstrated that these public health
measures including mandates protect
the health and safety have saved upwards
of 60 000 lives have prevented the
importation of the virus tenfolds at our
borders so there's ample evidence that
i'm happy to table with committee uh
that provides justification for these
vaccines well thanks very much we look
forward to tabling that information um
you know over 60 countries around the
world have abandoned all of their air
travel pandemic restrictions including
most of our european allies
and um you know p hack internal reports
suggest that air travel had almost no
impact on kovid community spread less
than one percent so it is questionable
why those would still be in place the
minister you're talking about um again
about science the cdc uh in the united
states with whom we share a border
says that it makes the most sense not to
differentiate between the vaccinated and
the unvaccinated and that
sub-jurisdictions don't need uh
to start making mandates so minister
let's talk about the mandates that you
still have in place
what are the current uh regulations uh
for air and train travel in canada with
respect to covet 19.
mr chair there are still many countries
around the world that require a proof of
vaccination for international travel
your mandates minister i've got less
than a minute
second currently the canadian government
has suspended our vaccine mandate for
our transportation sector so there is no
requirement for domestic
or international travel for people who
are leaving the country whether they
want to get on a plane or a train
so minister do you have to wear a mask
on a train or a plane
and if someone does not what should be
the consequence for that person
currently we maintain a mask wearing
policy for federally regulated
air or train um um
sector
it is scientifically proven that masks
reduce transmission upwards of 80
percent um it is
we're doing everything we can to protect
the health and safety of canadians and
it is the prudent thing in fact it's the
kind thing to do
10 seconds please minister
next to you minister your your prime
minister was was seen not wearing a mask
on a train just mere mere weeks ago was
that not prudent or kind of the prime
minister you can follow up on that
question at the next round mr barrett or
perhaps one of your colleagues can